here with more reaction to the
incredible life the legacy of rush
fox news contributor our other our other
good friend we have a lot of good
friends tonight dan bongino is with us
you know dan um i look at your success
and i champion your success
rush championed all of our success he
never thought it was a zero-sum game as
his answer was i'm only on three hours a
day and
an entire industry built up all of us
you know followed that forged path
this that he trailblazed for us
um and took a lot of heat for
yeah you know sean your reverence for
rush
you know if i may i won't share any of
the details but you know i i talk to you
once in a while and
whenever i ask you for advice on tv or
radio or my career i've just started a
few years ago you've been in this
industry decades now
like rush you would always say to me and
i i know you know you'd say well here's
what rush would say
i mean you said that so often and so did
levin and it was interesting watching
you
three titans of radio i mean you were
from 12 noon easter until nine o'clock
at night what was the what
what was the meat and potatoes of radio
it was it was limbaugh it was hannity
and levin
and to hear both you and mark always
who've taken me under your wing and
both given me amazing advice through the
years to always cite
rush really says a lot and and you know
it's interesting
neither you nor mark would ever mention
rush in his final weeks or days
and never mention his past i just
remember in the conversations
you would never mention anything about
successors or was because you just
it was verboten um it just really again
speaks to the reference but can i
can i make another point jonas you know
the greatness of rush limbaugh
it's really tough to talk about and i
think sports analogies work best for us
right
remember willie mays was a great
baseball player so was mickey mantle and
they probably had good 10-year runs
where they were the best in the business
but willie mays didn't invent baseball
rush limbaugh
invented the conservative national talk
radio space
beforehand there was talk radio but the
national talk radio
space that you and mark and glenn
and other you know titans of the
industry took from took from rush
he created the game and not only did he
create the game
he was number one in the game not for a
decade not for two decades
but more than two decades that is an
absolutely phenomenal achievement
you know it is and and i look at um
i look at somebody we are close friends
i'm not hiding the facts we're close
friends
and and i i look at every platform
that kind of built remember i mentioned
at the beginning of the program
rush syndicates nobody thought he'd
succeed 200 talk radio stations less
than that in the country now there's
over 4 000
saves the am band the fm band um
and then you've got web streaming then
you've got
podcasting where you're one of the most
successful podcasters out there
then you got fox news and and how that
was built
so this model just grew and grew and
grew and the appetite for
news and information especially in light
of the fact that journalism is dead and
the media mob is corrupt
and he always understood that too and
and they the one thing they do have in
common they hate us all
i mean the people that didn't like rush
and we always wear it as a badge of
honor and
and kind of like rolls off us like water
off a duck's back and it did rush too
yeah rush was around eight years before
fox news
even went on the air i mean before fox
news
there was only rush that was it and what
was it about rush like that's the
fascinating question
you know the french have that term right
that we've kind of adopted into english
to genocide
you know i don't know what it is that
that characteristic what was it about
it wasn't that he told stories sean you
and i tell stories on our show
everybody tells stories it's talk radio
was it that he was funny
well i'm not funny at all you're pretty
funny mark's very funny
but russian everybody's fun what was it
about rush
and the answer is who the hell knows he
was just
unbelievably special and sean one thing
again you've been in radio a long
long time from the local level to one of
the biggest radio hosts in the world
everybody dials it in once or twice
everybody
in radio you're sick you don't feel good
you take a lot of calls whatever it may
be
not rush and if he did it you could
never tell
i never listened to i would listen on
apps i'd go to wrestlingbar.com
i'd listen on the wcbm app wmal wherever
i was and i'm telling you
i never heard a time where i could tell
you all right
today he's dialing it in not once in 20
plus years and we all remember the first
time
we heard rush limbaugh and sadly i
remember the last time too
december 23rd and if i only would have
known as i was listening i was actually
brushing my teeth listening on december
23rd
in my bathroom that those were the last
moments that we were going to hear rush
limbaugh on the radio
you know i would have treated those
moments a little differently sean
yeah i uh i think we all would have i
mean
i don't think the country ever took them
for granted you know it's funny because
after every political cycle
and and russia experience this a lot too
he started when reagan was president was
there for bush 41
eight years of clinton mary matlin said
and i mentioned this
uh with harris faulkner and bill hemmer
earlier today
um you know mary matlin said well
how would we have survived without rush
during that years because he lifted
everybody up
well then that resulted in in three led
to
uh obama then we had donald trump and
now we have somebody
who's cognitively struggling um
and you know you think about it people
would always say well
what's rush going to talk about now
democrats elected or what's
what are you guys in talk radio going to
talk about now now are republicans
elected
uh there's always a lot to talk about
because the battles
and the principles that we care about as
conservatives that we care deeply about
they never change they stay the same
and and if i think one thing that mark
said that i agree with and i was saying
on my radio show
and i mentioned with newt is that i know
that rush would want
all of us nobody can ever replace him
but all of us that care about these
issues that learn
so much from him to up our game
and he'd want us to fight for everything
that he believed in
and his bucket list was to stay on the
air to keep fighting
to the very last day which is a lesson
also i think for a lot of us
you know sean you mentioned kaylee
mcinnes saying that she was a rush baby
i consider myself the same i mean for a
lot of us i'm in my mid-40s
the first time sean we ever heard the
true essence of conservatism
was when we accidentally flipped on the
radio and heard
uh talent on loan from god
you heard that he said who's this guy
that's the first time
the first time i've heard about how
awful half my brain
tied behind my back just to make it fair
time i mean the first
i didn't even know rio linda was a place
before rush limbaugh
i don't even think rio lindens knew rio
linda was a place before wrestlemania i
mean he was a legend
the first time i heard the essence of
conservatism
and it woke me from the doldrums of my
college years where i had been
indoctrinated
by a bunch of liberal lunatics was
sitting outside of queen's college
and flipping on the dial and hearing the
incredible voice of rush limbaugh
and it changed my life i would not be
here talking to you tonight
no doubt without russian god rest his
soul
amen uh great job good and faithful
servant
thank you dad joe